- This my granny, she gets me cookies.
- This is my second mom in New York.
- This a Popular Jewelry.
- Yes, it is.
(hip-hop music)
(yells)
(cash register chimes)
(street noises)
- [Narrator] At this
point you may be wondering
who the (car horn beeps) is A$AP Eva,
and where is this story going?
Hell, you might even be asking yourself:
what is this story all about?
Fair enough, let's start at the beginning.
Eva and her family immigrated to New York
from Macau in 1982.
Getting into the jewelry business
was a no-brainer for Eva;
she comes from a long line of jewelers.
- [Narrator] And then,
one day, the rap gods
smiled down on her and sent in ...
Travis Scott, Jaden Smith, Joey Bada$$,
Goldlink, Young Paris,
Wifisfuneral, Macklemore.
(laughs)
- [Eva] Okay, bling, bling, bling.
- Bling, bling.
(light classical music)
- [Narrator] Family and
jewelry are synonymous to Eva.
In fact, the day after her son was born,
she went straight back to work.
- [Narrator] Popular Jewelry is more
than the sum of its glittery parts.
It's a family, it's a home.
And Eva is the.
- My customer call me Gold Mother.
I have a lot of nickname
what they give me.
- [Woman] That's really sweet.
(light classical music)